die ersten Gäste trafen schon gestern
ein für Russlands Herrscher ist das
Treffen eine willkommene Bühne um von
seinem Krieg gegen die Ukraine und der
zunehmenden internationalen Isolation
abzulenken allzu viel Enthusiasmus
bringen die 17 Staatschefs und 30
Minister und Botschafter aus Afrika
nicht mit beim ersten Gipfel vor vier
Jahren in Sotschi hatte Putin viel
angekündigt aber wenig umgesetzt
es gab damals tolle Versprechen von
Investitionen und so geschehen ist
nichts das haben die Afrikaner nicht
vergessen
ein zentrales Thema Lebensmittel Putins
aufkündigen des getreideabkommens mit
der Ukraine hat für besonders betroffene
Länder am Horn von Afrika wo 23
Millionen Menschen auf Hilfe angewiesen
sind dramatische Folgen das Welt
Ernährungsprogramm bezog im letzten Jahr
80% seiner Weizen Ankäufe aus der
Ukraine
gleich nach dem Stopp des Abkommens in
der letzten Woche ist der Weizenpreis
schon um 9% gestiegen stand gestern um
16% und er klettert weiter für uns heißt
das wir können mit dem gleichen Geld
weniger kaufen also weniger hungernde
versorgen
Putins Propaganda schuld sei der Westen
verfängt er kaum die Kritik selbst der
Südafrikaner die sich im Ukraine kriegt
neutral geben ansonsten aber eng mit
Russland kooperieren war deutlich
wir sind enttäuscht dass das Abkommen
gekippt wurde und das werden wir den
Russen selbstverständlich klar machen
auch im Rahmen der G20 Gespräche
weit wichtiger für Putin dürfte die
strategische Zusammenarbeit mit
instabilen Staaten und militärregimen
wie Mali der Zentralafrikanischen
Republik und Eritrea sein sichtbar ist
das Zeichen russischer Militärhilfe die
Söldner der wagnergruppe Moskau liefert
von Libyen über Sudan bis Mali Waffen
und Kämpfer gegen Rohstoffe Erze und
Gold Vorteil für die afrikanischen
Warlords und militärm Machthaber
Menschenrechte Demokratie freie Presse
bei Wagner kein Thema die Folge die
Stabilisierung von Ost bis Westafrika
es ist wie ein Teufelskreis die Söldner
werden wegen Instabilität gerufen sie
schaffen noch mehr Instabilität um im
Geschäft zu bleiben denn diese private
Armeen schaffen keine Frieden ihr
Geschäftsmodell sind Krisen
benefitting from crisis das Motto des
Gipfels für Frieden Sicherheit und
Entwicklung dürfte deinen manchen Ohren
zynisch klingen
und über den Russland afrika-gipfel
heute in St Petersburg und die Lage in
der Ukraine spreche ich jetzt mit dem
Militär und Sicherheitsexperten Gustav
gresse der hier im Studio ist schön
guten Morgen guten Morgen Russland ist
ja zunehmend international immer
isolierter welche Interessen verfolgt
Putin mit dem Gipfel heute
erstens seine Version der Aufkündigung
des getreideabkommens unterzubringen
das zweite ist
Handelsbeziehungen aufrecht zu halten
Export von Erdöl ist ein Thema
Weiterführung von gewisses
Militäroperationen wir haben schon
Beitrag gehört erwartengruppe ist ein
anderes Thema
generell versucht Moskau über
einige afrikanische Staaten zumindest
auch in der UN die Stimmungslage die die
sozusagen die Verhältnisse in den
Abstimmungen ein bisschen mehr zu seinen
Gunsten zu kippen und daran arbeitet man
in diesem Gipfel
Praktikum gerade schon angesprochen das
Russland ja aufgekündigt hat und damit
auch eben viele afrikanische Staaten vor
den Kopf gestoßen hat weil sie eben von
diesem ukrainischen Getreide stark
abhängig sind nun hat Putin sogar gesagt
er würde das sozusagen auch ausliefern
selbst Russland würde quasi Getreide
liefern sogar teilweise als Geschenk was
ist da sein genaues strategisches
Interesse hinter er versucht die Schuld
für die Aufkündigung des
getreideabkommens dem Westen
zuzuschieben er meint etwa und das ist
ja nicht oft zitierte Behauptung die
natürlich nicht stimmt russische
Landwirtschaft und
russisches Getreide Stunden im Westen
unter Sanktionen und deshalb sei der
Preis zu hoch diese Sanktionen gibt es
natürlich nicht aber er behauptet das
und es verfängt sich in der russischen
Propaganda ist verfängt sich in der
Propaganda einige afrikanische
Diktaturen und strömen so quasi als als
Gerücht durch die Welt und hier wird
sozusagen eins draufgesetzt in jemand
sagt ja der böse Westen sanktioniert das
aber ich schenke es euch das ist
natürlich nichts anderes als ein pa Gag
aber es ist ein pa-gag der zieht und der
Öffentlichkeit bringt nun spitzt sich
die Situation auch im Schwarzen Meer
immer mehr zu durch eine Seeblockade
Russlands was könnte das zur Folge haben
und wie groß ist die Gefahr einer
weiteren Eskalation an dieser Stelle
also russland versucht den ukrainischen
Getreidehandel abzuschnüren durch
Angriffe gegen Häfen gegen verladepunkte
seit Mai hat man schon Brücken mögliche
Verkehrswege für einen alternativen
Export unter Beschuss genommen also das
ganze ist lange geplant und nicht eine
kurzfristige Racheaktion
und die den ausfuhrstopp über den See
ist also ein Teil davon ein Frachter ein
durchschnittlicher Frachter der also
dessen ausläuft transportiert etwa die
selbe Ladung wie 3.500 LKWs
3.500 LKWs auf normalen Straßen über die
Grenze zu bringen braucht enorme Zeit
die Zollabwicklung etc
braucht noch mehr Zeit das heißt man
kann sich sozusagen ausrechnen dass
durch die Blockade dieses See
verkehrsmann den Getreidehandel enorm
einführen kann nun kommt vom FDP
Verteidigungspolitiker Markus Faber der
Vorschlag diesen ukrainischen drei oder
getreideschüssen eben Schutz zu bieten
militärischen durch Geleitzüge und der
sieht da vor allem die Schwarzmeer an
Rainer die Bulgarien und Armenien
Entschuldigung Bulgarien und Rumänien
natürlich und auch die Türkei in der
Pflicht also alles NATO-Staaten für wie
realistisch halten Sie diesen Vorschlag
also man hat schon mal versucht den
sozusagen die Idee
unter die Leute zu bringen wobei eine
Eskorte aus ukrainischen Häfen den
meisten NATO-Staaten zu heikel ist
inklusive der Türkei und den USA
was allerdings noch nicht vom Tisch ist
und wo Rumänien und Bulgarien natürlich
auch
drauf bedingen ist eine Escort also so
eine Art Neutralität Patrouille dass man
aus den nato-häfen also aus den
rumänischen Häfen selber Schiffe unter
Schutz stellt denn ob man Odessa
ansteuert oder konstanter das ist lange
dieselbe Route und dann zeigt man
sozusagen ab
wenn die Russen im Schwarzen Meer
Trigger happy sind dann fangen sie an
auch Schiffe zu beschießen die Rumänien
ansteuern die Krisensituation die
dadurch gerufen wird bzw die jetzt schon
herbeigerufen ist dadurch dass Russland
scharf Schießübungen im Schwarzen Meer
veranstaltet und tot ist dass die
Versicherungsprämien für Schiffe die
Rumänien anlaufen die Bulgarien anlaufen
steigen das heißt der wirtschaftliche
Schaden ist schon da und das hier die
NATO zumindest die rumänischen Häfen
oder den See Verkehr geschützt und dass
man dann ukrainisches Getreide über den
Landweg in Richtung beziehungsweise über
kleine überflussschiffe über die Donau
dann eben in Hefen nach konstanter
bringt und von dort auf größere Schiffe
umlädt und dann exportiert das ist
durchaus eine realistische Möglichkeit
aber mal schauen was deine nächsten
Tagen Wochen rauskommt dennoch eine
höchst angespannte Situation und auch
heikle Situation im Schwarzmeer der Zeit
vielen Dank für das Gespräch Gustav
gresse sicherheits- und Militärexperte
über den Russland afrika-gipfel und zum
aktuellen Stand in der Ukraine